welcome back live look at the White
House where the coronavirus task force
is set to hold a briefing moments from
now and we'll take you there once it
starts in the meantime lawmakers say
they're a lot closer to a deal on a two
trillion dollar aid package after
Democrats blocked the build two days in
a row Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi are
now optimistic about working with
Republicans but only after being exposed
President Trump calling out the
Democrats for pushing elements of the
green New Deal in the negotiations we
almost had a deal the day before and it
was between Schumer and Mitch and it was
really a good solid you all of a sudden
they start throwing all of the little
green New Deal stuff in right and the
boardrooms what they look like and we
want green energy we want all this stuff
let's stop drilling oil they had things
in there that were terrible windmills
all over the place and all sorts of
credits for windmills they killed the
birds and ruined the real estate right a
lot of problems I mean a lot of problems
and I said I'm not signing this and even
though Nancy Pelosi's own bill is filled
with wind and solar tax credits thirty
five million dollars for the Kennedy
Center and corporate board diversity
standards the speaker claims that's not
the case it's not a bill I would have
written in terms of some things that
relate to Family Medical Leave that
relate to worker protections that the
ruling or worker protections but we that
can be done administratively we can find
other ways not enough money for
elections etc at this time all of
everything we're suggesting just relates
to covert 19 it's not about making law
and for the future
Katie takes a lot of you-know-what to
try to shoehorn some of this stuff in
there I mean did they think that no one
was gonna find out what do you think the
strategy was Katie
oh sorry Jesse there was a break-in your
microphone I think the strategy was that
Nancy Pelosi saw an opportunity to walk
all over Chuck Schumer in the Senate and
say we're going to push a lot of these
unrelated pork projects into this bill
because no one's going to question us on
it because
an emergency well it's a good thing
Republicans are paying attention because
thirty five million dollars to the
Kennedy Center is an affront taxpayers
everywhere Americans are losing their
jobs and they want to take hard-earned
money from them and give it to the
Kennedy Center when they could be doing
private fundraisers to make up the
difference that their if they're losing
money the other issue here that is
alarming is the pushing through of the
federalizing of our elections with the
ballot harvesting the long-term effects
of the early voting they wanted to push
through on this I mean Nancy Pelosi has
seen an opportunity here and Chuck
Schumer who said Sunday that everything
was going along just fine let her walk
up walk in walk all over him and blew up
the whole system on behalf of Democrats
seeking power rather than working on
something that will help everybody
regardless of whether they're Republican
or a Democrat yeah one Dana made that
point the other day everything was going
swimmingly until Nancy showed up and
make Chuck kind of cater to her every
whim at the last second it rocked the
markets do you think you think Chuck saw
that coming or was he taken by surprise
I think this whole description that
we're going through right now is the
caricature I think what's going on is
Democrats are out about protecting
America's workers and I think the
sticking point has been that there was
money being set aside for corporations
to make sure the big corporations to
make sure they didn't go under but that
the Democrats wanted transparency and
accountability for that money they
didn't want those big corporations to
simply get locked into buybacks and
executive pay raises they want to make
sure those companies are protecting and
keeping workers during this time period
and I think that's what we saw now from
the Democrat but what is that Harry knew
he'll the workers listen a lot it does
that's why I say I think with the way
we've presented it this evening is a
caricature of what's really going on you
have people saying I didn't know what we
have I think so I say I think the
president is quick to say he can put
Democrats at his disadvantage and making
it seem as if they're involved in some
kind of power grab or
self-promotion of some wild agenda but
you go back and you look at tarp you
know the Troubled Asset Relief Program
but from 2008 and you'll see similar
protections are in there and again so
many Americans felt the big business is
too big to fail they got the money but
the average person and Jesse you and I
agreed on this yesterday we do is still
we've got to put more money into the
average person's pocket so they can go
out and steal what's the deficit going
to do I thought it was something else
you're trying to do absolutely look at
the reality unemployment relief I do max
for employment versus three weeks I
gotcha
Gregg what are your thoughts on this
whole relief package I'll tell you what
I think that the only way you can fight
a virus is through diversity so I'm
really happy that that's a priority look
we are all making sacrifices I said this
before but what's depressing
is you know the very same people are up
to this very same tricks even when times
are urgent and ugly like I can get it
with the normal stuff when you're doing
a normal budget sneak all the stuff in
that you can so you get reelected but
that's not this time and what's doubly
depressing is that we really honestly
don't know who's doing it I mean we
could say you know Nancy flew in and
said stop it but she probably did not
write this stuff right you didn't do it
Chuck didn't do it they would have just
been happy to sign the damn thing and go
back and have a glass of wine so no one
knows who's ever screwing this crap up
it's not all Democrats and it's not all
Republicans who are the people that are
making this so complicated and where is
the media that's a great story you know
rather than screwing up every other
story about the virus why don't you try
to find out who the people are who are
mucking this up and then we can fire
those creeps that's probably the
lobbyists but what do I know Dana it
would be like if Republicans tried to
Jimmy in like defunding Planned
Parenthood in to the relief package like
if that happened the media would go wild
go wild and believe me the media would
find that one like that would that be a
problem that would not be hard for them
to find the thirty five million dollars
for the Kenan
Center is the new bridge to nowhere yeah
throwing that little thing in and it was
like how can this happen why are we
doing this just doesn't make any sense
I'm all for the Arts but this is not the
time or the place and if Nancy Pelosi
things that this wasn't something that
she wanted in there then she's got a
police or troops a little bit better
because they look really bad I think the
Democrats came once again you know you
think about the Schumer shut down yeah
every time they want to fight against
the president they end up with egg on
their face mmm maybe you know she's
fighting for the workers Dana just the
workers at the Kennedy Center that says
you can't see clothes like write a check
to the Kennedy Center she has enough
money to do it and the post office don't
forget about the post office all right